[Music]  it's time for a cheese social study your  quick look at what the Stars are posting  [Music]  Katy Perry went for the chop again she's  basically sporting a buzz cut now the  singer cited model Agnes Dean and a  singer auntie Lennox as her main  inspirations now check out Mandy Moore  shimmying her way into her birthday week  that this is us star turned at 33 on  Monday then there's Patrick Dempsey  sharing this sweet snap the actor  captioned the shot my vacation is always  more beautiful when I'm next to my  beautiful wife and Kate Beckinsale also  enjoying some downtime  the actress posted this series of bikini  shots looking fit and fabulous at 43  it's so nice  yeah it's really really nice